cette augmentation n'est pas massive
mais elle démontre bien que la pression
ne se relâche pas et qu'elle pèse
énormément sur nos soignants ce d'autant
plus que cela dure depuis des semaines
voire des mois
le deuxième élément préoccupant tient au
fait que ces chiffres nationaux
dissimule en réalité des situations
territoriale beaucoup plus contrastée
dans certaines régions le virgules
le virus circule moins voire ralenti
alors que dans d'autres nous constatons
des progressions rapides et d incidence
élevée nettement supérieur à la moyenne
nationale
c'est pour cela qu'au delà des règles
déjà applicable sur l'ensemble du
territoire national notamment le
couvre-feu à 18 heures nous avons décidé
la semaine dernière de prendre des
mesures spécifiques dans deux
territoires
les agglomérations de nice et de
dunkerque qui se sont trouvés rapidement
confronté à une véritable flambée
épidémique et je veux saluer le sens des
responsabilités de la population et des
élus de ces territoires
l'évolution préoccupante de 20
départements nous a par ailleurs conduit
à les placer sous surveillance renforcée
et vous vous en souvenez engager une
concertation entre les préfets et les
élus pour déterminer les réponses les
plus appropriées
qu'en est il à ce jour dans ses vingt
départements
le virus a continué de progresser à
l'exception toutefois des bouches du
rhône et de la moselle où l'on note un
reflux dont il faudra vérifier s'il est
durable dans ses vingt départements
les progressions enregistrées conduisent
à ce que les niveaux d'incidence des
passes pour la plupart d'entre eux le
seuil des 250 pour 100000 habitants et
pour deux départements le seuil des 400
il s'agit des alpes maritimes et du pas
de calais les taux d'incidence
s'échelonnaient si entre 217 pour la
meurthe et moselle et 340 2 pour parier
les départements de la petite couronne
trois autres départements les
hautes-alpes laine et loeb ont connu une
progression tel depuis une semaine
qu'ils ont franchi le seuil de deux cent
cinquante pour cent mille et s'ajoute
donc à la liste des vingt départements
placés sous surveillance renforcée
l'analyse des derniers chiffres et les
retours des échanges avec les élus de
ces territoires
me conduisent à arrêter quatre séries de
mesures
la première est d'étendre le dispositif
de confinement le week-end que nous
avons mis en place à nice et à dunkerque
à l'ensemble du département du
pas-de-calais
l'incidence ci est en effet en
progression très rapide 23 % au cours
des sept derniers jours et dépasse je le
disais dorénavant le seuil des 4 100
pour cent mille habitants soit presque
deux fois la moyenne nationale
le niveau de saturation des services de
réanimation se situe au plus haut de
tous les départements français les
règles du confinement s'y appliqueront
dès ce week-end du samedi 8 heures au
dimanche 18 heures deuxième mesure les
grandes surfaces commerciales non
alimentaires de plus de 5000 m² seront
fermés dans le pas de calais dans les
autres départements à risque
les évolutions observées ne justifie pas
de prendre à ce stade des mesures
équivalentes
elle appelle cependant des dispositions
supplémentaires pour limiter les risques
de regroupement et de brassage dans
l'espace public ou dans les grands
magasins
ainsi les grands centres commerciaux ou
grande surface commerciale de plus de 10
mille mètres carrés et non seulement
vingt mille mètres carrés comme jusqu'à
présent seront fermés l'obligation du
port du masque sera étendue à toutes les
zones urbaines de ces départements où
elle ne s'applique pas encore les
préfets seront également invités en
concertation bien sûr avec les maires
concernés à interdire ou à réglementer
l'accès de certains sites très
fréquenté pendant les week-ends où l'on
observe des regroupements de masse trop
souvent sans masque ni distanciation je
comprends évidemment le besoin de sortir
et de se retrouver notamment avec le
retour des beaux jours
mais les images que nous avons vues
encore le week-end dernier dans
certaines grandes villes y compris à
paris ne sont tout simplement pas
raisonnable par cohérence
les préfets pourront être amené à
interdire les manifestations organisées
dans l'espace public notamment pendant
les week-ends lorsqu'elles présenteront
un risque sanitaire avéré au regard de
leurs conditions d'organisation
ces dispositions entrent en vigueur ce
vendredi soir à minuit nous allons par
ailleurs accélérer significativement et
dès ce week-end la vaccination dans ces
23 départements dans des conditions que
nous allons vous préciser dans un
instant avec olivier ferrand
j'ajoute enfin de recommandation la
première est que nous fassions
collectivement l'effort de réduire nos
contacts sociaux et familiaux
vous ne vous en souvenez nous avions
posé ce type de recommandations pour les
fêtes de fin d'année et cela avait eu un
vrai impact pas plus de six personnes à
l'occasion des moments conviviaux ou
familiaux on sait que c'est souvent là
que les transmissions s'opère je vous
demande vraiment d'observer cette règle
de prudence au cours des prochaines
semaines
deuxièmes recommandations j'invite les
habitants des 23 départements concernés
à ne pas sortir autant que possible de
leur département ou de leur région
s'agissant des départements franciliens
c'est une demande de simple bon sens le
virus je les dis frappe de manière
encore inégale les différentes parties
de notre territoire
évitons de le diffuser là où il demeure
encore de moindre intensité
ces situations locales plus favorables
sont en effet encore très fragile et
rendent impossible
à ce stade d'envisager des mesures
d'assouplissement territorialisées ce
d'autant que d augmentation forte et
soudaine peuvent s'observer dans des
départements jusqu alors plutôt préservé
en sens inverse
certains s'interrogent où
s'interrogeront peut-être sur les
raisons qui conduisent le gouvernement à
ne pas aller plus loin en procédant
immédiatement à un confinement pure et
simple de ces 23 départements
je vous le disais la semaine dernière un
confinement même limité au week-end est
une mesure lourde d'autant plus lourde
que nous en avons déjà connu deux et que
nous supportons encore les effets d'un
couvre-feu à 18 heures qui dure depuis
maintenant deux mois
il ne peut donc s'agir d'une mesure
prise dans le doute de manière
préventive ou par anticipation
je ne dis pas je n'ai jamais cessé de
vous dire que l'évolution des prochains
jours ou des prochaines semaines ne nous
y conduira pas voir pourrait nous
conduire à envisager des mesures plus
dures encore on voit bien que dans
certains départements où l'épidémie
s'est envolé nous n'avons pas eu d'autre
choix mais je vous le répète à nouveau
nous devons tout faire pour l'éviter et
réserver cette option
ultime aux situations les plus dégradées
et après avoir tout essayé l'objectif
collectif c'est de tenir ensemble par la
mise en oeuvre de mesures utiles
nécessaires mais proportionnée par la
mobilisation de tous le temps que les
conditions météorologiques deviennent
moins favorables la circulation du virus
est le temps surtout que la vaccination
produise ses effets car c'est bien
d'abord et avant tout le déploiement le
plus rapide et le plus ciblé possible de
la campagne vaccinale qui nous permettra
de sortir de ce tunnel précisément où en
sommes-nous aujourd'hui du déploiement
de cette stratégie que je vous ai
présenté
ainsi qu'au parlement en décembre
dernier 3,2 millions de personnes sont
aujourd'hui vaccinées dont 1,8 ont déjà
reçu leurs deux doses
point très important il s'agit de
personnes très exposé c'est à dire
pouvant développer des formes graves du
virus et qui sont vous le savez des
personnes généralement âgées ou
présentant des pathologies ap les
comorbidités qui les rendent
particulièrement vulnérables j'insiste
auprès de vous sur le fait que la france
est en tête en europe pour la
vaccination de ces personnes les plus
vulnérables au virus
c'est à dire celles qui ont le plus de
probabilités d'être hospitalisée d'être
admise en réanimation et parfois de
mourir nous avons déjà franchi avec
succès une étape difficile mais majeur
avec un la vaccination de la population
sans doute la plus à risque
celle des ehpad et des unités de soins
de longue durée plus de 80 % des
résidents des ehpad ont reçu une
première injection et 60 % ont reçu
leurs deux doses et sont maintenant
protégés
nous avons ainsi franchi une première
étape cruciale dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie car comme vous le savez les
résidents d pad ont été cruellement
touché par la première et la deuxième
vague et représentent un tiers des morts
le lac au vide
en france c'est une incontestable
réussite que d'avoir réussi cette
vaccination la voie est désormais
ouverte à une adaptation des règles qui
régissent la vie sociale des résidents
et notamment l'exercice du droit de
visite pour les familles
je suis très sensibilisée par ce sujet
par les témoignages parfois très
poignant que je reçois nous avions
anticipé ce sujet humainement majeur que
je suis de très près avec olivier
ferrand et brigitte bourguignon en
saisissant le haut conseil de santé
publique qui vient de nous rendre
ces préconisations que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre très rapidement après
concertation pour que cette vie sociale
apaisée de nos aînés résidant dans les
ehpad et les unités de soins de longue
durée puisse retrouver sa pleine
dimension il faudra aussi que les
personnels de ces établissements se
fassent vacciner
trop d'entre eux ne l'ont pas encore
fait et je les invite solennellement à
le faire très rapidement
de manière plus générale deux éléments
vont nous permettre d'accélérer très
fortement la vaccination
premièrement les livraisons de doses à
la france vont s'accroître dans les
semaines à venir
illustration en janvier et février nous
avons reçu environ sept millions de
doses tous vaccins confondus à mars et
en avril
nous devrions en recevoir 22 millions
c'est-à-dire trois fois plus
deuxième élément nous pourront recourir
plus largement à l'un des vaccins astra
zeneca nous avons eu un effet
confirmation de l'excellente nouvelle
que nous annonçait le professeur fischer
jeudi dernier ici même la haute autorité
de santé a indiqué lundi sur la base
d'études scientifiques internationales
que sont désormais éligibles à ce vaccin
non seulement les personnes de 50 à 64
ans c'était déjà le cas mais encore les
personnes de plus de 65 ans ainsi que
les personnes atteintes de pathologies à
très haut risque de formes graves
je vous le dis là encore de la façon la
plus claire
ce vaccin est un vaccin très efficace et
les réserves qu'il a pu susciter au
départ n'ont plus lieu d'être
nous avons maintenant le retour
d'expérience de la grande bretagne où le
vaccin astrazeneca était utilisé sur des
millions de personnes et ce retour
établit clairement que ce vaccin est
aussi performant que le kaiser
le modern c'est donc un élément là
encore nouveau et il est très important
il faut donc utiliser ce vaccin appelé
ainsi d'ici la mi-avril 15 avril et sous
réserve que les laboratoires nous livre
selon le calendrier prévu nous devrions
avoir vacciné en première injection au
moins 10 millions de personnes soit la
totalité des personnes vulnérables
volontaire aujourd'hui éligibles à la
vaccination d'ici ni mais nous devrions
avoir vacciné en moins 20 millions de
personnes soit la quasi totalité de la
population volontaires de plus de 50 ans
et d'ici l'été nous aurons reçu
suffisamment de doses pour avoir
proposer la vaccination à 30 millions de
personnes soit les deux tiers de la
population de plus de 18 ans je veux
vous rappeler qui peut se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui où et comment d'abord pour
les personnes de plus de 75 ans vous le
savez la vaccination est ouverte depuis
le 18 janvier dans les centres de
vaccination en réservant sur internet
sur le site sante.fr ou en appelant le
centre le plus près de chez vous 28% des
personnes de plus de 75 ans a d'ores et
déjà reçu une première dose
je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous
n'arrive pas à obtenir un rendez vous je
sais votre impatience celle de vos
proches de vos enfants et je la
comprends parfaitement les doses arrive
progressivement et il en résulte que
nous ne pouvons pas vacciner tout le
monde tout de suite
comme vous le savez par ailleurs
l'industrie mondiale de production de
vaccin est en surchauffe
il faudra encore faire preuve de
patience mais n'en doutez pas vous serez
vacciner se dotant je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure que le rythme va s'accélérer
chaque semaine les centres ouvrent en
moyenne 320 mid nouveau rendez vous il
leur reste un ouvrir en
corps 850 milles d'ici la fin de ce mois
pour les personnes de plus de 50 ans la
vaccination vous le savez vous est
ouverte si vous avez ce qu'on appelle
une comorbidité c'est-à-dire un problème
de santé vous rendant plus fragiles face
au virus je pense notamment à l'obésité
au diabète à l'hypertension artérielle à
l'insuffisance respiratoire et aux
pathologies cardiaques ou si vous avez
un cancer depuis moins de trois ans pour
vous faire vacciner vous devez contacter
votre médecin
de plus en plus de médecins de ville
propose aujourd'hui la vaccination se
faire vacciner par son médecin traitant
reste le canal privilégié
lorsque vous avez l'une de ses co
morbidités car il est celui qui connaît
le mieux vos facteurs de risque j'ai
d'ailleurs ce soir invité un médecin
généraliste le docteur marie laure albi
qui a accepté de vous faire part de son
témoignage de terrain et je lui donnerai
la parole dans quelques instants
toujours pour les personnes ayant plus
de 50 ans et présentant une comorbidité
il vous sera également possible de vous
faire vacciner chez votre pharmacien
à compter de la semaine du 15 mars
une fois que nous aurons reçu la
prochaine livraison de vaccins
astrazeneca la haute autorité de santé a
donné son approbation et le décret
autorisant cette nouvelle étape majeure
dans notre stratégie de vaccination
sortira demain
la vaccination se passera comme pour la
grippe vous n'aurez pas besoin d'une
prescription médicale et vous pourrez
vous rendre directement à l'officier les
modalités concrètes concertée par le
ministère chargé de la santé avec la
profession vous seront précisées dès la
semaine prochaine si vous avez
maintenant entre 50 et 74 ans mais que
vous n'avez pas de pathologie
particulière
vous pourrez vous faire vacciner à
compter de la mi-avril
si vous avez moins de 50 ans vous pouvez
vous faire vacciner uniquement si vous
avez une pathologie à très haut risque
de formes graves de l'aco vide et ce
depuis le 18 janvier
si vous avez un cancer une maladie
rénale chronique sévère si vous êtes
transplantés si vous êtes atteint de
polypathologies chronique ou de trisomie
vous êtes alors prioritaire dans les
centres de vaccination et vous pouvez
aussi vous faire vacciner c'est votre
médecin traitant
je rappelle enfin que les soignants
médecins infirmiers sages femmes aides
soignants aides à domicile sont
éligibles à la vaccination depuis début
janvier
or seul un soignant sur trois est
aujourd'hui vacciner ce n'est pas normal
et cela compromet notre capacité à
lutter effectivement et efficacement
contre le virus
alors même que nous connaissons une
reprise épidémique inquiétante
le ministre des solidarités et de la
santé olivier véran y reviendra dans un
instant comme je voulais indiqué la
progression des livraisons va nous
permettre de faire monter fortement en
puissance
la vaccination l'enjeu est maintenant
que toute la chaîne suivent pour que ces
doses soit utilisée le plus rapidement
possible cela doit être le cas partout
et plus encore dans les territoires les
plus durement touchés par l'épidémie
ainsi ce sont 135 milles de nouvelles
doses qui seront alloués d'ici ce soir
dans les départements prioritaires
placés sous surveillance renforcée
sur ce total dix mille doses seront en
particulier adressé dans le pas de
calais nous en appelons à la
mobilisation générale
mr soignants hôpitaux tout le monde doit
être sur le pont y compris le week end
pour vacciner aussi vite que possible
nous sommes entrés dans une course
contre la montre contre l'épidémie et
nous avons besoin de la contribution de
tous les acteurs que je sais
parfaitement mobilisés je passe
immédiatement la parole au ministre des
solidarités et de la santé olivier
ferrand
mais ce premier ministre mesdames
messieurs c'est vrai notre volonté est
depuis le début c'est de vacciner en
sécurité bien sûr mais le plus vite
possible en privilégiant les plus
fragiles d'entre nous ceux qui sont avec
le plus grand risque de développer une
forme grave s'il devait contracté le
coronavirus vous le savez déjà depuis
deux mois les soignants les élus les
services de l'état les ars les
préfectures se sont jetés dans la
bataille de la vaccination en deux
comptant ni l'heure ni leurs efforts
face à la situation épidémique est dans
un contexte d'augmentation du nombre de
doses disponibles
cette mobilisation générale donc à
vocation à s'intensifier encore dans les
semaines à venir et c'est évidemment une
bonne nouvelle
une première marche de cette
accélération a été franchie aujourd'hui
puisque nous avons réalisé en moins de
24 heures plus de 200000 vaccination
dans notre pays dont plus de 60000
vaccination par astrazeneca
mais il marche importante va être
effectivement franchi ce week end
puisque nous avons demandé l'ouverture
d'un maximum de centres de vaccination
est d'ailleurs la création de centres
éphémère supplémentaires partout où cela
sera jugé utile de manière à vacciner
pendant tout ce week-end par avance
merci à l'ensemble des acteurs dans les
territoires en premier lieu les
soignants mais aussi les élus qui se
mobilisent pour pouvoir réussir cette
vaccination
ce week end nous en attendons beaucoup
nous mettons la barre haut nous verrons
à la fin de week-end comment cela ce
sera passé mais d'ores et déjà vous
pouvez compter sur la mobilisation de
tous notamment dans les départements qui
sont le plus en tension épidémique ou
effectivement un renfort de doses sans
déshabiller aucun territoire je rassure
a pu être organisée de manière
intensifier cette campagne dans les
prochaines heures ou demain au plus tard
les agences régionales de santé
communiqueront sur les modalités
opérationnelles de cette vaccination
un certain nombre d'entre vous qui
étaient inscrits en liste d'attentes
sont ou seront appelés par les
différents centres pour venir vous faire
vacciner
nous avons une liberté organisationnelle
au territoire
le maire de nice mme
c'est tout à l'heure qu'il comptait bien
écouler 12 mille doses de vaccins qui
lui ont été alloués pour ce week-end en
ile de france c'est un système de
tickets qui pourront être pris à
l'entrée des centres et qui permettront
ensuite d'avoir un rendez-vous dans le
week-end pour que évidemment c'est
intense et cette intensification aille
aussi avec une bonne organisation pour
tous en parallèle de cette vaccination
en centres j'ai demandé à l'ensemble des
établissements hospitaliers d'accélérer
encore la vaccination au sein des
hôpitaux que ce soit la vaccination des
professionnels de santé ou des patients
qui relève de la vaccination et en
parallèle
enfin nous avons demandé à ce que soient
déployés des fameuses barres d'hommes de
test dans les zones les plus en tension
épidémique au cours des prochains jours
en plus des 2 millions de tests que nous
réalisons déjà chaque semaine dans notre
pays ensuite je vais en vie a insisté
sur la vaccination en ville par les
médecins généralistes dans un premier
temps et donc bientôt par les
pharmaciens cette vaccination en ville
elle prend son essor
c'est un pilier de notre stratégie pour
apporter le vaccin au plus près de nos
concitoyens entre la semaine dernière et
cette semaine ce sont plus de 800 milles
vaccins qui ont été livrées aux médecins
par l'intermédiaire des pharmacies la
semaine prochaine ce sont 750 mille
vaccins supplémentaires en réponse aux
commandes qu'ils ont passée ils ont été
très nombreux à le faire jusqu'à hier en
tout donc plus de 1 5 millions de
patients ont vont recevoir une première
injection de vaccin de la part de leur
médecin
ce que nous souhaitons ce que souhaitait
patience évidemment que ces doses une
fois qu'elles sont attribués elle puisse
être administré le plus vite possible
en d'autres termes au regard de l usage
sanitaire les doses n'ont évidemment pas
dormir dans des frigos de pharmaciens ou
de médecin et je demande à l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé de
s'organiser pour récupérer ces doses le
plus vite possible lorsqu'elles sont
livrés de manière à les administrer dans
la foulée à leurs patients je sais que
la mobilisation des médecins est pleine
et entière de même que celle des
pharmaciens
par exemple les doses qui ont été
commandés la semaine dernière et qui
sont alloués en pharmacie cette fin de
semaine doivent être récupérées d'ici
lundi
sans quoi elle pourrait être réaffecté
ou utiliser directement par les
pharmaciens vu la situation nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre de faire
autrement évidemment que d'aller vite
le premier ministre l'a dit les
pharmaciens pourront vacciner en
officine et c'est une bonne nouvelle à
compter de la mi mars et le décret
sortira demain qui leur permettra de le
faire je résume donc en pratique pour
vous qui nous regardaient ce que
représente cette mobilisation pour ce
week-end
si vous avez 50 ans ou plus et que vous
avez atteint d'une maladie chronique
d'une co morbidités l'hypertension du
diabète à nantes ans et un antécédent de
cancer une bronchite chronique
obstructive
si vous avez plus de 75 ans quel que
soit votre votre état de santé par
ailleurs et que vous n'avez pas pu
encore prendre rendez-vous dans un
centre de vaccination
renseignez vous voudrez des informations
auprès de vos médias locaux près de vos
élus auprès de votre centre de
vaccination le plus proche ou pourquoi
pas de votre médecin pour vous faire
vacciner j'ai demandé aux agences
régionales de santé de communiquer dans
tous les territoires le plus vite
possible pour donner ses indications ça
ne veut pas dire que tout le monde pour
être vaccinés ce week-end
évidemment nous n'avons pas suffisamment
de vaccins pour cela mais ça veut dire
que nous souhaitons encore intensifier
notre campagne vaccinale le vaccin fait
partie des armes dont nous disposons
pour lutter contre l'épidémie comme l'a
rappelé le premier ministre
chacune chacun d'entre nous en
disposerons progressivement mais nous
avons également d'autres armes
d'abord vous avez la possibilité je le
rappelle de vous faire tester dès que
vous avez des symptômes ou quand vous
avez un doute ou quand vous avez été en
contact avec une personne malade
chaque semaine nous réalisons donc
toujours plus de 2 millions de tests
dans les laboratoires dans les
pharmacies dans vos communes par vos
employeurs
fidèle au principe de solidarité de
notre pays
ces tests sont gratuits entièrement pris
en charge par la sécurité sociale afin
qu'il n'y ait pas de frein quand je dis
que vous pouvez vous faire tester ces
vous évidemment qui vous fait tester
vous l'avez massivement fait avant les
fêtes
et cela a contribué à éviter une flambée
épidémique depuis la semaine dernière
nous avons également déployé des tests
salivaires dans les écoles mais bientôt
nous le ferons également dans les
crèches dans les établissements
sanitaires dans les établissements
médico sociaux dans toutes les
structures qui accueillent des personnes
en situation de handicap en lien avec
sophie cluzel secrétaire d'état en
charge des personnes en
capé avec brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué à l'autonomie face à une
situation épidémique à risque et je vous
le dis au moindre doute à la moindre
alerte au moindre symptôme fait de nous
tester mais se faire tester ça ne suffit
pas l'autre arme dont nous disposons et
qu'il est absolument indispensable
d'utiliser sans modération c'est la mise
à l'abri ou isolement c'est à dire quand
on est malade ou quand on n'est qu'à
contact d'une personne malade on évite
absolument d'entrer en contact avec une
autre personne pour éviter de propager
le virus nous avons il ya deux semaines
porté la durée de l'isolément de sept à
10 jours pour une personne malade elle
est restée de sept jours pour une
personne qu'à contacter depuis le début
en france nous avons fait un choix
assumé celui de ne pas contraindre à
l'isolément mais de permettre à tous de
pouvoir le respecter en responsabilité
de faire en sorte qu'une personne malade
ou qu'à contacter quelle que soit sa
situation puisse observer la durée
d'isolement qui convient dans de bonnes
conditions matérielles
nous avons supprimé le délai de carence
je vous le rappelle nous avons créé des
procédures facilité de demandes d'arrêt
de travail en ligne
nous avons identifié des équipes d'appui
à l'isolement-- vous propose le passage
d'un infirmier ou d'une infirmière
libérale chez vous pour tester votre
entourage si vous êtes malade vous
propose également des cellules
territoriales d'appui à l'isolément avec
des travailleurs sociaux qui peuvent
vous aider jusque dans vos démarches
administratives vos courses où vous
aider pour la garde de vos enfants mais
au fond le succès de l' isolement
il repose avant tout sur chacun de nous
je voudrais vous parler brièvement de
l'étude qui s'appelle l'étude comme
corps elle est pilotée par quelqu'un que
vous connaissez
si vous êtes fidèle à ses conférences de
presse le professeur arnaud fontanet
elle est pilotée par l'institut pasteur
en lien avec santé publique france et
l'assurance maladie
et cette étude elle souligne que la
première barrière contre l'épidémie
c'est évidemment le respect des gestes
barrières mais aussi la réduction des
contacts et le respect scrupuleux de l'
isolement lorsqu'on est soi-même affecté
aucun contact
ces travaux ils sont intéressants il
confirme que le risque les risques de
contamination sont principalement accrue
lors des repas dans des réunions privées
sur les lieux de travail
lorsque
vigilance se relâche notamment lorsqu'on
finit par ôté son masque les personnes
en télétravail présente par exemple un
risque d'infection réduits de l'ordre de
30% et dans près de la moitié des cas
qui sont survenus sur le lieu du travail
dans l'après la moitié des cas
d'infection de transmission du virus sur
les lieux professionnels
les personnes qui ont contaminé leurs
collègues de travail étaient
symptomatiques et ne s'était pas isolé
il faut pas avoir de pudeur si vous avez
des symptômes qui vous laissent penser
vous pourriez avoir contracté le vide
n'attendez pas le résultat de votre test
n'allez pas travailler en attendant de
voir comment est-ce que ça évolue si
vous avez des doutes vous devez vous
isolez réaliser le test et on vous
accompagne pour cela l'étude montre
aussi que l' isolement est souvent mis
en oeuvre trop tardivement et
insuffisamment au sein de la cellule
familiale au sein du foyer
parce que les patients attendent de plus
en plus le retour de leur test pour
s'isoler de leurs proches et seulement
60 % des personnes reconnaissent s'être
mise en isolement vis-à-vis de leurs
proches dans leur foyer tant qu'elle
n'avait pas le résultat de leurs tests
donc vous voyez à chaque fois ce sont
des risques de contamination qui sont
évitables par l'attention que nous
portons chacun d'entre nous au quotidien
à la protection des personnes autour de
nous je le rappelle s'isoler c'est se
protéger soi même et ses protégés les
autres l'épidémie est là chaque jour
nous sommes encore trop nombreux a
contracté le virus
on peut encore limité nos contacts
respecter les allemands et vaincre cette
épidémie enfin je voudrais dire un mot
évoqué une question qui est celle de la
vaccination des soignants
le taux devait le taux de vaccination
des soignants
sur le papier il dépasse aujourd'hui le
taux de couverture classique contre la
grippe observés chaque année chez les
soignants en pratique ce sont 40 % des
soignants en ehpad et 30% des soignants
sur l'ensemble du système de santé qui
sont vaccinées clairement ça ne suffit
pourtant pas nous disposons je le
rappelle le vaccin efficace
à commencer par le vaccin astrazeneca le
professeur alain fischer est revenu la
semaine dernière devant vous sur ses
qualités et sur son efficacité
je vous le dis en franchise quand on est
soignants il est de notre responsabilité
de se protéger soi-même et d'éviter
d'exposer ce
dont on prend soin au risque d'un virus
qui peut les percuter durement en se
vaccinant vous protégez vous et vous
protégez vos patients en évitant de
mettre en danger leur prise en charge
parce que vous tombez malade et par
ailleurs il se pourrait aussi nous avons
des études très intéressante qui tendent
à montrer que la vaccination protégerait
jeu mais encore un peu de conditionnels
protégerait la transmission du virus et
donc protégerait de la contagiosité est
donc ça éviterait évidemment de
contaminer des personnes fragiles en
ehpad ou à l'hôpital c'est pourquoi dès
demain j'écrirai une lettre à l'ensemble
des soignants de notre pays qu'il soit
en ville qu'il soit à l'hôpital qu'il
soit en établissement médico social pour
les inciter très fortement à se faire
vacciner mais également évidemment pour
les remercier pour leur mobilisation
sans faille depuis plus d'un an dans la
lutte contre cette épidémie
je suis convaincu que nous observerons
dans les prochains jours une adhésion
grandissante des soignants à la
vaccination
c'est absolument nécessaire à ce stade
je laisser la parole à marie laure albi
médecins généralistes dans le 14e
arrondissement à paris et qui souhaitent
témoigner de sa pratique de la
vaccination en cabinet et pendant que le
docteur albi nous rejoint je voudrais
par avance remercier toutes celles et
ceux qui ce week-end dans les centres de
vaccination vont se mobiliser salué le
renfort que nous apporterons les
personnels sapeurs pompiers qui seront
mobilisés à l'instigation du ministre de
l'intérieur
cher docteur je vous cède la parole mais
c'est le premier ministre monsieur le
ministre mes chers concitoyens je suis
un peu ému de témoigner d'une année
d'activité de
de nos collègues depuis cette épidémie
qui nous frappe tous et qui nous a
conduit à changer considérablement notre
manière d'exercer depuis le début de
l'épidémie il ya un an
les médecins généralistes et l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé se sont
mobilisés de façon incroyable inédite
pour suivre les patients qu'ovide à
domicile en ville puis pour des pages et
des pistes et racé accompagner les
allemands de nos concitoyens par la
persuasion par des entretiens par de
l'accompagnement
on a trouvé là on a trouvé là un
partenariat tout à fait inédit avec nos
collègues infirmiers libéraux l'hôpital
l'assurance maladie
la rs et nous avons souvent pu
travailler dans des locaux prêtés par
les collectivités locales ces souffles
suffisamment extraordinaire pour le
souligner tout le monde s'est mis au
service cette épidémie pour lutter avec
l'ensemble du pays et préserver la
population avec l'arrivée des vaccins
franchement c'était un message d'espoir
et nous n'en pouvons nous n'en pouvons
plus d'attendre
donc fin décembre et début janvier
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
s'est engagé aux côtés des hospitaliers
commencer à vacciner très rapidement
nous avons ainsi appris à nous organiser
nous avons été aussi dans les ehpad pour
les aider à vacciner là encore binôme
infirmiers et médecins travaillant de
concert et enfin nous avons pu être
soutenus avec toujours les mêmes
partenaires pour créer ces centres de
vaccination répartis sur le territoire
que vous connaissez pour y avoir
peut-être été en ce qui concerne les
populations de plus de 75 ans mais qui
sont entièrement animé est organisée par
l'ensemble que je vous ai cités tout à
l'heure c'est à dire les professionnels
de santé de ville
soutenu par les collectivités locales
des institutions comme la rs l'assurance
maladie et c'est tout à fait une
organisation qui a permis en tout cas
dans mon quartier le quatorzième de
vacciner près de 3000 personnes de plus
de 75 ans depuis le début où nous avons
été fourni en dose ça suppose une
organisation complexe puisque comme vous
savez le vaccin doit être délivré dans
certaines conditions et utiliser
d'autres et c'est pour ça que nous
étions tout à fait volontaire pour aller
travailler tous ensemble dans un système
collectif et puis maintenant nous
arrivons dans une nouvelle phase une
phase qui va permettre d'accueillir dans
nos cabinets nos patients les plus
vulnérables bon ça un petit peu changé
les catégories on est passé de 60 à 50 à
64 ans le jour suivant c'était 50 74 et
enfin c'est tout le monde c'est plus
simple et ça veut dire que nous appelons
nos patients nous les faisons nous leur
donnons des rendez-vous un certain
nombre nous appellent et je pense que
sur les 1600 patients qui sont
actuellement mes patients y en a environ
400 qui sont en affection longue durée
donc ça donne une catégorie assez simple
de patients vulnérables y en a d'autres
mais au moins ces 400 là j'espère en en
vaccinant 50 par semaine il faut aller
plus vite on en mettra 100 en un mois ou
deux avoir protégé l'ensemble de ces
patients de 50 à 60 ans puisque en
accueillant 60 ans qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables et après on
passera aux autres donc je pense
vraiment que cette phase est une phase
d'espoir j'ai pas besoin d'encourager
les patients à venir se faire vacciner
parce qu'il appelle tous les jours mais
je pense que ça permet aussi de
d'envisager l'avenir avec plus
d'optimisme depuis huit jours bon je
vous donne un exemple concret mais je
pense que mes collègues ont fait la même
chose
les cinq médecins du cabinet dans lequel
je travaille se sont réunis pour
proposer des séances de vaccination à
peu près une par jour pour l'instant
fonction de l'arrivée des doses y
compris le samedi et pourquoi pas le
dimanche
après demain dimanche monsieur le
premier ministre on est obligé d'aller
au centre de vaccination puisque vous
nous avez attribué des deux donc on
verra comment ce partage donc nous nous
prenons les flacons à côté chez le
pharmacien de proximité en parfois je
les laisse dans son frigidaire pour
puisqu'on nous accuser d'avoir des bons
prix giller au moins celui du pharmacien
je vais les prendre au fur et à mesure
nous allons les utiliser
et d'autre part nous appelons ces
patients et tous viennent et on les
vaccine dans un cadre consultation
simple on pourrait avoir des échanges et
c'est un moment des changes de
réassurance et de plaisir enfin de
contentement parce que clairement la
population française a vraiment très
envie
des de vacciner rapidement je terminerai
pour dire partir pour dire pardon
nous nous sommes à peu près actuellement
les deux tiers des médecins généralistes
qui se sont donc engagés dans une
organisation encore une fois inédite
puisqu'il s'est pas du tout comme ça
qu'on le travail est maintenant pour
accueillir nos patients pour consacrer
une partie importante de notre activité
à les protéger le plus vite possible
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est quand même un des éléments
essentiels de lutte contre l'épidémie
et c'est aussi là d'une certaine manière
la relation que nous avons avec nos
patients qui prend tout son sens
elle facilite cette vaccination elle
permet un dialogue serein qui est bien
nécessaire en ce moment et nous
souhaitons continuer à nous adapter et à
participer à cet effort de tous au
service de la population parce que nous
sommes aussi accompagnés par des
bénévoles par des patients qui nous ont
proposé nous donner un coup de main
parce que toutes ces organisations
agiles sont consommatrices de temps mais
nous le faisons bien volonté pour
contribuer à ce travail collectif de
protection de la population
je terminerai par un appel à mes
collègues soignants ce que vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure moi me choque
vraiment venaient de tous vous faire
vacciner dans nos cabinets autres
soignants je sais qu'ils ont en principe
les soignants hospitaliers sont pourvus
dans leurs hôpitaux mais venez tous aide
à domicile infirmières aides soignantes
venez tous vous faire vacciner nous vous
accueillerons nous le ferons parce que
c'est très important de protéger les
personnes que vous soignez mais
également vos familles un certain nombre
de soignants ont été très durement
touchée par le cos vide et je pense
essentiel que vous vous protégez au plus
vite vous et les personnes que vous
soyez merci premier monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
cher docteur à la fois pour votre
témoignage qui est surtout pour votre
engagement
mesdames et messieurs je n'ignore rien
de ce que vous avez vécu de ce que nous
avons vécu au cours des 12 derniers mois
12 très longs mois
la période que nous vivons est une
épreuve et un combat c'est aussi et
surtout un engagement collectif
ah non beaucoup de choses ont changé
nous avons progressé nous avons appris
nous avons progressé sur la connaissance
du virus sur les gestes barrières sur
les tests sur les vaccins bien sûr et
nous avons appris sur l'impact du
confinement son impact économique son
impact social et je le dis à dessein son
impact humain comme je voulais toujours
dit le confinement n'est pas impossible
mais il n'est pas inéluctable
ce choix du nom confinement a cependant
une contrepartie pour le gouvernement
c'est de mettre un coup d'accélérateur
sur les tests et sur les vaccins et très
vite dès ce week-end et pour nous tous
c'est de respecter plus que jamais les
gestes barrière de redoubler de
vigilance
ces prochains week-ends même si vous n'y
est pas contraint rester le plus
possible chez vous limitez ce qu'on
appelle vos interactions sociales
si vous avez des symptômes olivier
ferrand vous la détestez vous est isolé
vous sans aucun délai nous devons tenir
ensemble je crois en nous et en notre
force collective
je vous remercie et avec olivier verrons
nous allons maintenant répondre aux
questions de la presse
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre
yoann usa y pour ses news hier le
porte-parole du gouvernement a évoqué un
retour à une vie je cite plus normal dès
le 15 avril prochain soit dans six mois
est-ce que vous pouvez ce soir nous
confirmer ce calendrier et pouvez-vous
également s'il vous plaît nous décrire
ce que signifie pour vous une vie plus
normale je remercie mon soir monsieur le
premier ministre pour rebondir sur la
question la question de mon confrère
qu'on vous dit revenir à une vie normale
à la mi avril
alors vous avez évoqué un chiffre à la
mi-avril ce seront 10 millions de
personnes selon vous qui seront vaccinés
à ce moment là on si on compare avec
notre notre voisins européens le royaume
uni eux ce sont 20 millions de personnes
qui sont vaccinées alors qu'ils
commencent à desserrer l'étau est-ce que
donc selon vous cet objectif est
réalisable
de retour à la vie normale et une
deuxième petite question concernant les
doses d'astrazeneca qui ne sont pas
utilisés par les soignants et qui
dorment en quelque sorte que faire de
ces doses est ce qu'il ne faut pas les
réaffecter dans les régions sous tension
dans les pharmacies notamment qu'est ce
que vous allez qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire de ces doses la merci de
questions d'abord sur les chances du 15
avril c'est une chance qui si vous le
permettez n'est pas tout à fait nouvelle
dans les objectifs que nous avons
décliné en matière de vaccination
puisque effectivement comme je le
rappelais tout à l'heure au terme des
livraisons qui sont programmés à cette
date nous devrions avoir je le dis
j'espère même dépassé le seuil des 10
millions mais comme je suis un homme
raisonnable responsables et prudents
j'ai donné ce chiffre des 10 millions
c'est surtout en terme de population
vaccinée et je vous rappelle que de ce
point de vue là les comparaisons
européennes
vous avez cité u ou extra européenne
trouve un peu leurs limites
c'est à dire que nous
nous aurons vacciner des personnes près
est particulièrement vulnérable
les 10 millions en question c'est à dire
que normalement nous pourrons en
attendre un impact fort sur la pression
hospitalière est effectivement en
conséquence de quoi nous pourrons si
tout cela se confirme
sous réserve de l'évolution des données
épidémique
il faut bien entendu être extrêmement
sourcilleux nous pourrons effectivement
envisager à ce moment-là de desserrer un
certain nombre de contraintes c'est en
tout cas notre objectif clair
olivier sur les doses d'astrazeneca et
pour compléter peut-être la question sur
les vaccins sera donné qu'à nous avons
fait le choix de la haute autorité de
santé nous a enjoint à faire un choix
qui était de permettre aux soignants de
se protéger très vite avec le vaccin
astrazeneca les soignants sur un certain
nombre se protéger rappelé aujourd'hui
soixante mille vaccination en
astrazeneca dans notre pays pour par des
soignants l'hôpital pour parce que font
les médecins généralistes et qui est
extrêmement précieux dans leur cabinet
il reste effectivement des doses qui ne
sont pas à ce jour utilisé et dont on
sait qu'elles ne seront pas utilisées à
très court terme dans leur totalité
vous posez une bonne question qui était
la fois la question et la réponse
puisque nous avons décidé de permettre
d'utiliser ces doses à trois aînés cas
dans tous les territoires qui les
contiennent pour pouvoir les protège les
proposer à la population qui relève de
la vaccination dès ce week-end dès ce
week-end ainsi il n'y a pas de doses en
réalité dormantes à l'hôpital sont des
doses destinées aux soignants et aux
malades hospitalier qui seront demain
destiné aux soignants aux malades
hospitalier hospitalisés et aux
personnes qui sont vaccinées en ville
sur la première question c'était le
retour à la vie normale
anat à date du 15 avril on ne donne pas
au fond de date
on tire d'abord des enseignements de ce
que la france a connu l'année dernière
et de ce que des pays autour de nous
connaissent on sait que la période du
printemps les conditions climatiques
sont manifestement moins favorable à la
circulation du virus
on le sait parce que tous les pays qui
nous entourent ont vécu une période qui
allait de mai à septembre plutôt
clémente de ce point de vue là
ajoutez à ça les fait de la vaccination
on peut penser légitimement que d'ici à
la mi-avril ou peut être la fin avril ou
peut être début du mois de mai on peut
pas le dater précisément on n'a pas de
boule de cristal
il ne soit possible de relâcher un
certain nombre de contraintes si la
situation épidémique le permettent ce
qu'ils veulent ce qui veut dire deux
choses
ce qui veut dire que dans les prochaines
semaines et jusqu'au 15 avril on peut
pas espérer relever le niveau de
diminuer le niveau de contrainte qui
aujourd'hui pèse sur les français
hélas donc il ya pas de réouverture
programmée ou anticipés dans cette
période et ce qui veut dire aussi que
nous préparons la possibilité ensuite
d'alléger les contraintes c'est la
situation épidémique le permet nous
l'avions fait l'année dernière et nous
leur ferons dès que l'occasion se
présentera bonjour je me marot pour la
fp sur les stocks de vaccins astrazeneca
est peut-être que vous pouvez éclaircir
quelque chose vous vous dites les
médecins les soignants emparez vous de
ces doses et pour ne pas qu'elle dorme
dans vos frigos
mais les médecins disent eux nous on
n'est pas suffisamment livré on doit
annuler des rendez vous et c'est la dgse
la direction générale de la santé qui ne
nous a pas livré à temps donc on ne sait
pas très bien qui croire in fine est ce
que vous pouvez clarifier ce point et
questions supplémentaires pour les
médecins ou les pharmaciens qui
vaccinerait en astrazeneca donc petit
coin avec des flacons qui contiennent 10
doses s'il leur reste une dose ou deux à
la fin qui doivent-ils vacciner est ce
qu'il doit vacciner hors critères ou
doivent-ils parce que le flacon menace
d'être périmés jeter le flacon à la
poubelle ont déjà atteint de l'agencé de
presse ap de questions si je peux
comment expliquez vous qu'il y a
toujours vingt mille
infections et les centaines de morts par
jour malgré les mesures en place et
malgré les efforts d'anticiper le vario
anglais et quels sont vos dernières
données sur la source de ces infections
vous avez évoqué les lieux de travail ou
est ce que c'est aussi transports
publics les écoles et deuxième question
nous observons les policiers les
salariés des agences gouvernementales
qui enlèvent leur masquant public qui
mangent dans les restaurants clandestins
comment comment comptez vous lutter
contre ce phénomène
est-ce que vous avez les chiffres sur
combien de fonctionnaires ont été
verbalisés pour violation des mesures
barrières olivier pour première question
les deux premières questions
alors d'abord les médecins ont été
nombreux et je les remercie pour ça à se
mobiliser à nous dire nous on voudrait
évacuer leurs malades et donc on leur a
proposé de réserver un certain nombre de
doses de vaccins
comme vous le savez c'est toujours le
même problème et la même équation plus
on a deux doses plus on peut en donner
pour la vaccination
et quand il ya plus de demande que de
doses disponibles on est obligé de
rationner et donc on expliqué au médecin
la première semaine ce qui a été fait
avec le docteur habib j'imagine
vous pouvez réserver temps de doses de
vaccins on se charge de les livrer dans
la pharmacie qui est à côté de chez vous
de votre cabinet médical vous demande
d'aller les chercher ces vaccins et de
prévoir rapidement de faire de vacciner
vos malades
c'est simple dans 96% des cas toutes les
livraisons se sont déroulés en temps et
en heure au bon endroit avec la bonne
quantité
quand on pense aux milliers de points de
distribution de pharmacie que ça
concerne ça veut dire tout le monde a
super bien travaillé
les médecins les pharmaciens des
logisticiens et ça c'est positif
ensuite il y à un certain nombre de
pharmaciens qui disent aujourd'hui bas
nous les médecins ne sont pas encore
venus chercher les doses de vaccins
qu'ils avaient commandés donc qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait
c'est là que je dis je demande aux
médecins de venir chercher rapidement
les vaccins qu'ils ont commandés chez
leur pharmacien sans quoi au bout de
quelques jours on va dire aux
pharmaciens
si personne n'est venu chercher ses
doses vous pouvez les réallouer ou à des
médecins qui vous disent ben moi
j'aimerais bien vacciné plus mais je
manque de doses ou vaccinez vous même ce
sera bientôt possible pour eux c'est
ce point de vue là vraiment basique sur
lucky vacciner en cas de doses en plus
dans les flacons on peut faire confiance
aux gens qu'ils soient médecins
pharmaciens infirmiers
quand ils voient qu'ils auraient une
dose dans un flacon il trouve qu'ils
vaccinent et de préférence évidemment
des personnes qui sont dans la cible
mais la règle d'or c'est ne jamais jeter
du vaccin
quand on peut vacciner quelqu'un donc il
ya de la souplesse de ce point de vue là
sur la question vous poser la question
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya encore hélas
trop de décès trop de gens qui tombent
malades dans notre pays malgré le
couvre-feu malgré les mesures qui sont
en vigueur
nous adaptons des mesures à la situation
épidémique
parce que nous tenons compte de l'impact
psychologique social économique culturel
pour les français qui est très lourd de
chaque mesures que nous prenons pour les
protéger de la circulation du virus et
nous proportion cela avec un objectif
sauver un maximum de vies protéger les
hôpitaux et éviter que les gens soient
trop nombreux tombé malade mais à la
main j'observe que dans un certain
nombre de pays dans lesquels les
commerces sont fermés depuis plus de
deux mois dans lesquelles les écoles
sont fermées depuis plus de deux mois
aucun enfant devait à l'école en
allemagne depuis plus de deux mois par
exemple les commerces dits non
essentiels pardon pour l'expression ils
sont fermés depuis plus de deux mois la
vie s'est arrêtée comme donc confinement
généralisée du printemps dernier en
france c'est très long là bas l'épidémie
a bien diminué et aujourd'hui elle a
arrêté diminué elle a arrêté diminué
l'italie également avec un confinement
qui a été long enregistre à nouveau une
petite accentuation du nombre de cas et
c'est donc cela montre bien que 1 les
mesures que nous avons en vigueur dans
notre pays sont efficaces certains en
doutent elle je parle du couvre-feu
or il n'y a plus un scientifique
aujourd'hui pour dire le contraire
est-ce que ça suffit face à la montée
des variants nous le regardons nous
l'objet qui vont jour après jour semaine
après semaine
là où ça ne suffit pas manifestement
dans les départements dans lesquels
l'incidence est trop élevé et où les
hôpitaux se remplissent nous prenons des
mesures supplémentaires en concertation
avec les élus localement et là où ça
tient
eh bien nous tenons en attendant des
jours meilleurs et en attendant d'avoir
protégé par la vaccination davantage de
français je vais répondre juste je perds
mes oliviers je veux je compte plett là
la réponse et c'est précisément
évidemment
dia chez les médecins des gens qui n'ont
pas encore la possibilité de se faire
vacciner parce que les médecins manquent
de doses c'est aussi vrai des centres de
vaccination je le dis et je le répète on
ne peut pas vacciner toute la population
prioritaire française anne un jour mais
c'est précisément parce qu'il ya cette
situation qu'il faut que nous évitions
par tous moyens que par ailleurs des
doses reste inemployées c'est notre
objectif
effectivement soyons clairs pour le
vaccin sera zeneca que ce soit dans les
hôpitaux par rapport à certaines
réticences qui s'étaient exprimés que ce
soit la plus tôt pour des questions
d'organisation cas évoqués olivier
ferrand dans des pharmacies on a
effectivement des doses et qui sont
restées inemployées ça il faut à tout
prix qu'on et redéploie pour autant même
ce redéploiement à ce jour ne va pas
évidemment suffire à vacciner l'ensemble
de la population française je vous ai
donné tous les chiffres
tout à l'heure il s'agit ça madame des
contrôles vous confirme que nous
effectuons des contrôles votre question
consistait à savoir si des
fonctionnaires s'étaient fait verbaliser
c'est ça alors il y en a peut-être
certains je n'ai pas de relevés
statistiques en règle générale fait des
fonctionnaires font leur travail
j'ai eu connaissance effectivement de
certains abus qui sont sans doute
choquée de vous passer pensée et les
ministres sous l'autorité dès qu'elles
se trouvent ses fonctionnaires en
diligenter les investigations et les
poursuites nécessaires
ce que je peux vous donner de façon un
peu plus globale c'est-à-dire pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
s'agissant des de contrôle du respect du
couvre-feu et des mesures sanitaires en
général dans la semaine qui s'est
achevée le 2 mars
sachez que nous avons contrôlé en france
4 124 mille personnes ce qui a donné
lieu à 43 milles verbalisation 5000
335 commerces et restaurants puisque
vous avez évoqué cette catégorie ont été
contrôlés au titre du couvre feu et il y
a eu 225 verbalisation c'est trop enfin
je souligne quand même le respect et je
veux le dire par par nos concitoyens
quel qu'il soit globalement des règles
que nous éditons on a également je vous
rappel depuis plusieurs heures
depuis le mois de décembre dernier
comptabilisé 255 rassemblement festif
clandestins qui ont donné lieu à des
interventions des forces sécurité
intérieure lesquels ont conduit à 255
interpellations dont 192 poursuite à
caractère pénal
je voudrais aussi pour souligner leur
travail indiqué que les agents de la
direction générale de la concurrence et
la répression des fraudes conduit
également des contrôles bon ce sont des
contrôles évidemment plus ciblée ils se
sont élevées 647 la semaine dernière et
j'en profite pour vous rappeler que nous
avons aux termes d'un décret paru il ya
quelques jours augmenter les amendes
pour les rendre plus dissuasive et
notamment vous le savez lorsque ce
qu'apple un établissement recevant du
public ne respectent pas les règles de
fermeture dont il fait l'objet
eh bien nous avons fixé augmente et
passe exactement de 135 euros à 500
euros ce qu'on appelle la mode
forfaitaire larmande forfaitaire dit
majoré et passer à 1000 euros
et tout ça est multiplié par cinq
lorsque ce n'est pas une personne
physique qui est en cause mais une
personne morale allez on va faire deux
dernières questions et on arrête
bonsoir messieurs jean un niveau d'eau
pour europe 1 vous avez pointé le taux
de vaccination trop faible chez les
soignants question serbe ne faudrait-il
pas rendre obligatoire cette vaccination
chez les soignants et puis pour rebondir
sur la question d'un concert des épi
vous évoquez déjà le retour à la vie
normale vous parlez de l'incontestable
réussite de la vaccination dans les
ehpad vous comparer à d'autres pays
je caricature on al impression presque
tout va bien est ce que vous faites pas
preuve d'un peu trop d'autosatisfaction
alors même que les réacs sont au bord la
saturation et qu'il ya des centaines de
morts par je vous remercie
alors je réponds olivier répondra sur la
vaccination sur la vaccination
obligatoire d'aidés soignants je ne
pense pas vraiment à voir c'est
d'autosatisfaction et je dois vous dire
au contraire que si des nôtres de voir
monsieur 2 de préparer la suite on a
parlé de l'échéance du 15 avril
et après l'heure n'est pas à envisager
des réouvertures leur est effectivement
comme je l ai dit à plusieurs reprises
tant la semaine dernière qu' aujourd'hui
à une situation préoccupante en
particulier vous l'avais dit dans les
services hospitaliers et donc ce que
nous cherchons à faire c'est toujours à
respecter cet équilibre entre mesures à
caractère sanitaire pour protéger nos
concitoyens pour éviter les afflux dans
les établissements de santé et permettre
à une vie de continuer à se dérouler
parce que nous savons que des mesures
trop dures sont susceptibles d'avoir des
conséquences extrêmement lourdes tout en
restant tout en restant en permanence
mobilisés surveillants territoire par
territoire pour prendre les meilleures
dispositions possibles qui peuvent être
je ne m'en suis jamais caché des mesures
encore plus difficile que celle que nous
annonçons aujourd'hui je le répète c'est
un combat collectif
si les françaises et les français et je
sais qu'il le souhaite
veulent que nous puissions nous
affranchir il faut déployer la
vaccination il faut qu'ils se fassent
vacciner dès que les vaccins sont là et
c'est notre rôle et il faut aussi qu'il
respecte les règles que la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire appel de leur part
et ils les connaissent parce que ce sont
aussi vous le savez des armes puissantes
pour empêcher l'épidémie de se
développer
olivier
oui c'est vrai que nous vivons des temps
difficiles et on a besoin de tenir et
nous avons aussi besoin de perspectives
sur la vaccination des soignants
d'abord je voudrais vous dire ma
conviction profonde c'est que l'adhésion
des soignants la vaccination va
augmenter elle va augmenter je crois que
le temps de la réticence est derrière
nous il ya eu des réflexions et puis
avoir des doutes
est-ce que tel vaccin est plus adapté
que l'autre est ce que les effets
indésirables de tels vaccins justifie qu
on se vaccine
oui oui bien sûr que ça justifie qu on
vaccine se protéger soi-même et protéger
les autres c'est pas un problème franco
français regarder autour de nous n'est
pas rare que le taux d'adhésion des
soignants à la vaccination soit un peu
plus faible que le taux d'adhésion de
population générale mais souvenez-vous
quand on parlait de l'adhésion des
personnes âgées en ehpad et qu'on nous
disait vous vous regardez dans les
enquêtes d'opinion 50 60 % des personnes
âgées accepte de se vacciner on va
atteindre les 85 % des personnes âgées
en ehpad bientôt qui auront accepté la
vaccination et ceux qui n'auront pas
accepter ce qui trompe pas vaccinés pour
la plupart sont des gens qui ne peuvent
pas être vaccinés pour des raisons de
santé
donc je crois profondément qu'on va
améliorer tout ça je vais écrire au
médecin je vais écrire aux infirmières
je vais écrire aux sages-femmes j'écris
au kiné à tout le monde
une lettre encore une fois pour dire ce
qui est très bien dit le docteur habib
tout à l'heure tous que la nation leur
doit depuis plus d'un an du combat
qu'ils mènent partout dans les hôpitaux
et en ville et je vais leur dire que ce
combat il le mènerons encore mieux s'ils
sont eux-mêmes protégé pour eux et pour
les autres et je leur demande de se
faire vacciner
il y à des offres de vaccins pour eux
ils sont prioritaires et c'est normal
donc je pense que ce sera suffisant
si vous posez la question de savoir et
si ça ne suffisait pas j'aime parler et
si parce que je pense qu'on peut avancer
différemment mais si ça ne suffisait pas
alors nous pourrions envisager une
saisine du conseil consultatif national
d'éthique qui seraient fondées comme il
a déjà pu le faire sur des vaccinations
qu'elle soit obligatoire ou non à nous
dire s'il faut aller au delà
mais encore une fois je préfère me
projeter à demain à cette lettre pour
nos soignants aient un impact aussi de
la communication vous nous permettait
d'avoir alors directement leur direction
pour qu'ils se protègent
merci beaucoup merci messieurs